a lot of people get analysis paralysis
and they'll just sit there and they'll
plan their first video for 3 months and
your first video is not going to get
views period it's not your first 10 are
not going to get views I can very
confidently say that so stop sitting
there and thinking for months and months
on in and just get to work and start
uploading like all you need to do this
this applies to people who have not
uploaded videos but have dreams of being
a YouTuber is make 100 videos and
improve something every time do that and
then on your 100 first video we'll start
talking like maybe you can get some
views there are very freak cases like
liak Koshi or Emma Chamberlin who have
really good personalities and it doesn't
take them so as many videos and it's
just like people who are 7'5 and making
the NBA like yes there are freak cases
you can find but for the average person
like us you know who don't have these
exceptional personalities and you know
backgrounds in film making just make 100
videos improve something each time and
then talk to me on your 101st video how
do you improve something each time the
second one just I don't know put more
effort into the script the third one try
to learn a new editing trick the fourth
one try to figure out a way that you can
have better inflections in your voice
the fifth one try to you know study a
new thumbnail tip and implement it the
sixth one try to figure out a new title
there's infinite ways that's the beauty
every little thing can be improved and
they can never not be improve there's
literally no such thing as a perfect
video need motivation watch your top 10
with believe Nation hey it's EV
Carmichael and I make these videos
because as a young entrepreneur I
struggled to keep my business going I
had no friends I had no mentors I had no
role models and the thing that Sav me
was learning from the success stories of
famous entrepreneurs and in their
stories I got motivation and I also out
strategies for what I could do to grow
my business and not stay stuck and I
still need their stories for motivation
today so today let's learn from one of
the best Mr Beast and my take on his top
10 rules of success
enjoy rule number two is build a great
team you've curated a team of people who
are just so hardworking it's like all
about the work yeah there's no fluff I'm
blessed I I agree we got a lot of great
people here and obviously you know like
the the videos we do where I'm now I'm
drawing blank like Selling Houses for a
dollar putting a million Orbeez in
someone's backyard or whatever the
stupid things you're doing or filling a
person's house with slime like I can't
do that on my own obviously I need help
so uh Bless yeah so how did you go from
hiring one editor mhm to hiring the next
person the next person the next person
it's literally just like it's not like I
just woke up one day and I have dozens
of employees like was just like I've
literally just been hiring like a person
a month for the last four years like you
know as the the videos it's like cuz
it's also not like you know I gave a
homeless guy 10 grand and then you know
the next day I'm buying everything in
five stores you know and and needing a
hundred people to fill dozens of U-Hauls
and stuff like it was just a slow
progression up and along the way we just
pick up a person and another person
another and how do you find people cuz I
think that's something that YouTubers
have a really hard time with I don't
really know I mean I've been do like I
said four years like it's a very very
very slow grind hiring all these people
uh I honestly there are way more
qualified people for that uh if someone
knows how to find great to please reach
out to me I'll pay you rule number three
is create multiple streams of income do
you know how many income sources you
have that's an interesting one well
let's see we have Beast Burger uh febles
we have a a company where we dub
channels which runs our Mr Beast espanol
and stuff like that we do that for other
people we have Mr Beast Mr Beast gaming
Beast reacts yeah merch as another one
honestly I'd have to like open my bank
account look through it cuz like there's
also like sub opportunities like we
occasionally do things for like we built
this app we had people put their finger
on the app yeah yeah so we're building
other apps in the future what would you
say your main source of income is if you
to pick one thing gosh so I'll say this
cuz I twe you you can throw it up that
uh Beast Berger has done over 100
million in sales and obviously that
number has grown a lot bigger since then
so like but again it's cuz it's
something people can repeatedly buy
merged the best margins but you know
it's you just like a burger or whatever
you know is something someone can order
multiple times a week merch someone
going to buy like twice a year rule
number four is focus on quality do you
think you'll ever make a video that gets
1 billion views I think maybe one of the
videos we've already made might get a
billion views which one do you think
probably like the the squid game video
with enough time I mean it's only a year
old and it's already on 300 million or
some of the newer ones we've we've done
have gotten like 100 million views in a
month um so those for projected over 10
years CU YouTube's not going anywhere
probably one of those so over time they
don't necessarily Plateau what's
interesting we were literally jumping
right I love it it's good um so I I'm
firm believer that it's much easier to
hypothetically get 10 million views on
one video than 100,000 on 100 and part
of why it's much easier in my opinion is
like if you make a really good video
it's just so Evergreen and it never dies
because YouTube when you open up YouTube
and look at the videos they're just
serving you whatever they think you'll
like the best you know and so if you
just make a great video uh and it's
constantly just above every other video
you know even two years down the road
then they'll just keep serving it and
never stop you know which is why it's
much easier to make one great video than
a bunch of mediocre ones what about 1
billion subscribers you've uh passed
PewDiePie is the most subscribed to
YouTube channel uh when do you think you
get a billion uh let me do some math
real quick so we're on 120 so you think
about this no I don't honestly I because
one thing you'll find if you want to
gain subscribers if you want to get
views if you want to make money any
almost any metric in this uh video
creation space if you want something it
all comes back to okay well then just
make great videos so instead of like f
focusing on all these arbitrary vanity
metrics I just kind of focus on the one
thing that gets me all that which is
make good videos also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific specific plan of
action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five is plan ahead when did
you then start hiring people for to look
forward to other videos right so not
just stuff that you've shot and needs to
get done or production slow progression
I mean yeah cuz I'm I'm sure like uh
just three years ago we probably like
came up with what we were going to film
like the week before you know I mean
like like planning months ahead and like
working on cuz you know like if I'm
bearing myself alive I can't do that
next week right or I could now because
I've done it but but when we first came
up with the idea like that's something
that takes like 100 days like you got to
build the coffin you got to BU it for 10
days to make sure it works you got to
you know figure out how to get air into
it and the medic and all that type of
stuff then make the area look nice so
it's pretty on film and figure out
lighting da d da so um it's just like
the video is just slowly got more more
complex and obviously I just had to
bring people on to figure it out how far
in advance are you planning do you know
Tariq just how far out is the calendar
isn't it three
months yeah right now it's not too far
out three to four months rule number six
is leverage your brand how do you plan
to expand the business ooh that's where
it gets fun I think for starters you
know I just want to keep making the best
videos possible I have to reiterate I'm
going to sound like a broken record but
everything I do stems for that cuz if I
stop making the best videos people stop
watching and then febles is irrelevant
beachburg irrelevant all the companies
are just literally irrelevant so that
and then stemming off from that um next
I really want to get into making mobile
games I think that'd be a lot of fun cuz
we have a gaming channel that gets like
20 million views a video and then I
really want to scale up febles launch
new products we're going to launch
cookies and then Beast Burger we're
getting into building physical location
so in 2 weeks we open our first physical
Beast Burger we have 2,000 virtual we're
building that and then based on how that
goes I want to to build 10 and then 50
and then 100 physical locations um and
just you know keep leveraging the brand
I like pushing myself and I see it as a
sport and like going hard in business
and and building them um even though
it's stressful and it's very difficult
and like sometimes I'm like you know you
have a mental breakdown you're like why
am I doing this why did I push myself so
hard but then when you're not doing it
you're just depressed so it's like a
weird system a weird situation but I
love it but sometimes I don't rule
number seven is help others I think
going to be a billionaire I believe that
of course he is so when you're a
billionaire and you have all the money
in the world and you got a nonprofit and
all that what are you doing with your
life well and you don't have to make
YouTube videos anymore yeah what are you
doing with you have you ever thought of
that well the thing is like how do I
answer the the problem is like the
billionaire is going to be illiquid
right like cash it' be pretty hard just
because we spend so much but I mean you
could technically probably with
beatburger and everything just with how
valuations today argue that but yeah but
the thing is like Cashwise yeah um but
no I mean even then I just would grow
the businesses more like I just who the
cares like I genuinely think like in a
100 years they're going to look back and
be like damn these guys just ran around
like monkeys and just obsessed over
bigger houses money matter know exactly
yeah if I had that kind of money I would
just grow the businesses and probably
when I'm like 60 or 70 hopefully I have
I mean I'm I'm pretty ambitious I don't
know I could be poor but maybe there's a
world where I have like a $1 billion
dollars I'd love to just you know in
Starvation in Africa or in diseases like
Bill Gates like do some cool like
that rule number eight is improve your
retention after we uh hung out yesterday
I went back and watched the FBI video
again and I watched the first 40 seconds
and I was sitting with Colin showing him
like a lot of what we talked about I was
seeing in those first 40 seconds and I
was like you really do all those things
and those first 40 seconds were so
jam-packed and you introduced so many
new things like so much new stuff
between both the visuals too I mean even
the the the concept that you say in the
first 40 seconds first of all the
visuals are already changing but you
also say there's an NFL stadium there's
a private jet and there's a maze this is
why you should watch the video see these
things yeah and like the the thing
people undervalue the most is literally
the first 10 seconds of the video like I
can almost I think I can quote it uh I
tied up an FBI agent and I have $100,000
in this bag here's a knife good luck and
I just run away like it gives you
everything you need no wasted words
short and concise and then tension how
much time do you spend on those openings
I'm a perfectionist I I really it's so
important like that's your uh first
impression for everyone clicking on the
video so like I like the whole time
leading up to that I'm just constantly
obsessed with mostly the first minute
just like making sure like if I were to
click on this video I would like the
first minute and that it would hook me
rule number nine is learn to Market so
you do I don't know what you would call
them but like integrated ads in your
videos and you do it I would say
masterfully it's like part of the video
you're talking about brand deals brand
deals is that what you would call that
yep so it's a brand deal it's part of
the video it's still really exciting to
watch and yet there's a plug for the
brand in general just brand deals since
you brought it up um integrating them
well I think that's something a lot of
creators don't do like they'll just do a
brand deal out of the blue they'll just
be filming a video and then around the 3
minute Mark just start talking about a
random company yeah and you I feel like
if you don't want viewers to click away
and you want people to not get pissed
off and call you to sellout you got to
find a way to integrate into content and
ideally use the in the video to make it
better like is the easiest thing you do
when you do a brand deal is just tell
people how you're using money from the
brand deal to make your content better
and if you do that like no one cares now
they're supporting you for it and you go
from being a sellout to like oh I'm
doing this to make better videos for you
guys you know I don't know if you can
share but with those Brands when you
have discussions with them are they
strict about how long you need to be
talking about it or is it more about
they're leaving control to you about the
artistic element of it the problem is
the the ones who don't give us artistic
element we just don't really work with
anymore because it's just you know we
get 100 million views a video now and I
can confidently say I know how to
entertain them and convert them better
than these random Brands so uh yeah if
if they don't give us that freedom I
just won't work with them so you have
that leverage but for smaller creators
it's a lot harder yeah and they're
they're going to just say 45 seconds
here's what you say take it or leave it
and it's like pretty brutal because I
think just in general if Brands were
more accommodating to let creators tell
their story of the brand and talk about
the brand in a way that felt a little
more natural I I think it a it' be less
cringe it people would be less likely to
go and you know tap tap tap Skip and uh
obviously it would convert better but
they're just so afraid and they want
this standardized things and we number
10 the last time before some very
special bonus Clips is do what you love
so how much has your like personal life
changed like with the money coming in
and the fame I mean this has been my
whole life outside YouTube socially like
anything crazy or no I just basically
Fus I'm not as Bland as it gets but I'm
I'm pretty open about it like I don't
try to be someone I'm not I love
building businesses I love making
content I love my life like it's not one
of those things where I need an escape
like this is just what I want to do and
I hope for the next 20 30 years I can
just do it every day money to me is just
a way to you know help people and grow
the business and do entrepreneural
things yeah I don't materialistic
objects like I think is the worst way
you can live your
life what how do you set goals for
yourself as a creator for your channel
assuming you do hit 100 million do you
set another goal what is that I got it I
love this question so back in the day my
goals used to be very subscriber based
or view based but one thing I've learned
and I think you've probably learned this
as well is like everything you want as a
YouTube Creator every freaking goal you
want to hit whether it be subscribers
you want to hit a million or 10 million
or whatever will come if you just make
the best videos possible so my goal and
this is what it will be till the day I
dies to make the best YouTube videos
possible and so if my hypothetical goal
was was 300 million subscribers in 10
years that will happen if I just make
the best videos possible if my goal is
to get 50 million views a video that
will happen if I just make the best
whatever it is you know just focus on
making the best videos possible and all
these other vanity arbitrary metrics
will just fall into play I don't mean
that in an arrogant way but that's just
kind of like the mindset you have to
have like go hard and believe in
yourself no honestly I think that's one
of the ways you have a career longterm
in the space is you don't get too hard
set on anything um because things just
change what people enjoyed watching and
what was interesting 3 years ago is not
what's going to be interesting 3 years
from now and the most of the time the
creats who try to just do the same thing
over and over again or are too afraid to
change or um scale up into just one
specific thing like as that kind of dies
or people get tired of it you just can't
sustain it forever right like I love
SpongeBob but I'm not going to watch
SpongeBob every day for 10 years in a
row you know what I mean maybe like
three or four you know what I mean but
eventually you have to innovate and
adapt
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Casey niat check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I do a 20 hour day at
least 5 days a week if not six days a
week um and there's usually a day where
I'll sleep I'll sleep in and get six or
seven hours and I have a three-year-old
at home uh and I think that especially
in the world of YouTube with sort of